hola quiero iniciar esta charla
haciéndoles una pregunta levante por
favor la mano quién tiene sueños
ambiciosos
ok ahora levante la mano quien tiene
sueños tan grandes que a veces siente
que los sobrepasan a sí mismo que piensa
que no los va a lograr alguien
todos soñamos desde que somos niños es
una constante en nuestra vida cuando
somos adultos seguimos soñando y cuando
somos ancianos pero los niños son
eternos soñadores aunque no todos logran
sus sueños esa es una realidad hoy te
quiero compartir tres grandes
aceleradores para que puedas cumplir
todos tus sueños para que esos sueños no
sean más grandes que tú mismo
primer acelerador mentalidad protagónica
la mentalidad protagónica es tomar
absoluto control de lo que me pasa a mí
en tiempo presente nadie entendió
también la parte de los sueños como walt
disney que decía si lo puedes soñar lo
puedes
lograr
cuando nosotros hablamos de la
mentalidad protagónica hay que entender
que hay dos cosas que en la vida
nosotros no vamos a escoger
el contexto y la genética no escogemos
nacer altos chaparros guapos feos ser
pobres ricos no escogemos el apellido
nacer en un país tercermundista o en un
país desarrollado
yo no elegí que mi mamá a los 6 años me
dejara en un internado
no haber conocido a mi papá biológico en
el internado me pasaron muchas cosas
muchas de ellas
las olvidé por muchos años
abusos violaciones
lesiones violencia física violencia
emocional hambre frío había personas que
se entretenían apagando unos cigarros en
la espalda
producto de todo lo que yo viví en el
internado
deje de soñar perdí toda mi seguridad y
me volvió un millón o mejor dicho me
orinaba de manera diaria en la cama
y déjenme decirles que las violaciones
no dolían tanto que esas eran
silenciosas
nadie sabía solo la persona que lo hacía
yo pero ser unión en un internado ese sí
es un problema eres criticado eres
señalado no comes bien porque tienes que
ir a lavar tus sábanas y tus cobijas y
cuando llegas a la jungla del comedor ya
se acabó todo si un día tocará que
lloviera es el terror de todos los
millones porque por escarmiento ibas a
dormir sin sábanas y cobijas no se iban
a secar yo no escogí todo esto que a mí
me pasó pero no toda la malo en el
internado había una época de mucha fe de
mucha esperanza
todos los días nos ponían a rezar el
rosario la biblia las monjitas nos
decían cómo quieres alimentar el
estómago si no alimentas primero el
espíritu
en las fechas del viacrucis me acuerdo
que había un crucifico muy pesado que
nadie podía las monjitas nos decían si
tú rezas con mucha fe y le pides algo a
dios te lo va a conceder
yo tenía muchas ganas de tener un papá
alguien más fuerte más grande que yo que
protegiera al niño de todo lo que le
estaba pasando siempre estaba con la
mirada perdida siempre inseguro siempre
con miedo
y entonces yo cargaba la cruz estaba muy
flaco desnutrido no comía bien pero yo
tenía fe y la música me decía al oído
carga la fe con mucha con mucha con
mucha fe porque si no tu papá no va a
venir por ti y no te vas a dejar de
orinar en la cama
dos cosas pasaron en nueve años que yo
lo intente
nunca
aparecía mi papá
y yo nunca dejé de orinarse en la cama
esto es solo un pequeño fragmento de
todo lo que me tocó vivir a mi los
primeros 18 años de mi vida
para acelerar te y para cumplir tus
sueños entiende esto hay dos caminos
carretera de la víctima y carretera del
protagonista
yo quiero hacerles una pregunta aquí
honestamente quien de aquí se siente que
está en la carretera del protagonista
que tiene mentalidad ganadora que
levante la mano
ahora quien de aquí siente que está en
la carretera de la víctima alguien se
siente víctima que levante su mano
nadie normalmente todos decimos que
somos ganadores que somos protagonistas
y nunca somos víctimas
déjenme les doy unas características
entre lo que es una víctima y un
protagonista víctima todo lo que me pasa
a mí es culpa de alguien más estoy
por el gobierno llegue tarde por
el tráfico 2 soy experto en señalar en
criticar en juzgar él está mal él está
gordo él está hecha para rock él es
flojo él es huevón
y tres me la pasó perdiendo mi tiempo y
mis energías en cosas que no me suman
la mentalidad protagonista también tiene
sus características
todo lo que me pasa en la vida es para
bien aunque te metan más de 20 años a la
cárcel
2 no busco el reconocimiento allá afuera
cuando lo tengo dentro de mí y 3 no
pierdo mis energías y no me desgastó en
algo que no me suma ahora cómo puedo
pasar de víctima protagonista todos
pasamos cosas terribles en nuestras
vidas todos tienen sus historias unos
chicos unos grandes hay una palabra y
para los que nos gusta la venganza los
que tenemos coraje los que tenemos
rencor
escuchen esta frase y repitan en su
mente
mi venganza será mi perdón la mejor
forma de avanzar es perdonando
perdonando te a ti mismo y perdonando te
quien te hizo daño todas las personas
que me hicieron daño cuando yo era un
niño a mis treinta y tantos años los
busqué yo ya estaba alto y grande ya me
podía defender yo me acuerdo lo que tú
me hiciste te perdono te invito a comer
y te doy las gracias por lo que hiciste
me diste es una historia que contar todo
lo que me pasa en la vida es para bien
cuando tú haces eso
vas a creer en ti y nada ni nadie te va
a mover y entiendan esto la diferencia
entre la gente exitosa y la gente
extremadamente exitosa es algo la gente
extremadamente exitosa se la cree tiene
mentalidad
protagonista
segundo gran acelerador tu repetición es
tu reputación
eres lo que haces no lo que dices que
haces eres tu repetición tú puedes tener
mucho una mentalidad protagonista este
es un main set muy poderoso pero no
haces el trabajo de nada te va a servir
para entender la palabra reputación hay
que comprender que hay dos tipos de
reputación la aparente y la real
desafortunadamente todos nos enfocamos
en el aparente que piensan los demás de
mí mis papás en mi trabajo mi novia que
dice la sociedad como me ve reflejado no
nos enfocamos en la reputación real que
pienso yo de mi cómo me siento conmigo
cuál es mi ser cuál es mi esencia cuando
tú te enfocas en ti en tu reputación
real
tu reputación aparente va a brillar como
muchos en la historia una de mis frases
favoritas dice michael jordan paso a
paso no concibo ninguna otra forma de
lograr las cosas
repetición a repetición thomas alva
edison no ha fracasado he encontrado
10.000 maneras que no funcionan diez mil
formas de repetir tu repetición es tu
reputación una de las frases que más me
llegan coco chanel durante mi infancia
solo ansía ser amada
todos los días pensaba en cómo quitarme
la vida aunque en el fondo ya estaba
muerta
sólo el orgullo me salvó su orgullo la
obligó a tener repeticiones se aferró a
una máquina de costura y por días por
semanas y por años se obligó a volverse
buena y se volvió un referente en la
industria de la moda que tienen estas
tres personas en común y muchos agentes
de cambio y fuera de serie michael
jordan el mejor basquetbolista de todos
los tiempos tomas alva y son un
precursor de la electricidad coco chanel
referente en la industria de la moda
se apegaron a sus repeticiones y sus
repeticiones les dieron su reputación
esta foto que están viendo aquí cuando
yo salí del internado
no tenían las condiciones mi mamá no
terminó ni la primaria mi papá biológico
no sabe leer tengo más de 100 primos
hermanos algunos no los conozco y el que
más terminó la primaria yo vengo de una
familia que no hay profesionistas pero
yo un día me permití soñar y dije por
qué no a los 30 años voy a ser doctor en
derecho
pero me enfoqué en un día a la vez un
libro a la vez una lectura a la vez una
guía a la vez un estudio yo no me di
cuenta solamente me enfocaba en los
exámenes a los 30 años ya tenía cuatro
maestrías era doctor en derecho y era
doctora en educación dos doctorados me
preguntan cómo lo logré con repeticiones
estoy a tres días de iniciar un
movimiento sinergética en redes sociales
yo ya era doctor en derecho ya tenía mis
empresas y mis amigos me decían estás
locutor es catedrático de escuelas de
prestigio como que vas a ser tip vox no
tienes ni redes sociales estás loco qué
estás haciendo yo no tenía la capacidad
de hacer una historia me tomaba una hora
hacer una historia algo que hoy me toma
15 segundos pero yo entendía que si me
aferraba y todos los días hacía 5 vídeos
sin parar al día de hoy no he parado
podía lograr algo si me enfocaba en las
repeticiones hoy somos más de 1.9
millones de seguidores en todas las
plataformas y el movimiento está más
vivo que nunca es muy chiquito pero yo
le digo siempre a mis amigos cinco años
de intentar hacer esto para decir que
estoy haciendo algo cinco años de
repeticiones tú repetición es tu
reputación
cuando estaba en el internado
no tenía seguridad en los tiempos de
diciembre hacíamos campaña nos llevaban
a todos los niños a que cantáramos
canciones de roberto carlos voy a subir
una montaña yo no podía cantar yo no
reclamaba yo no hablaba yo no servía
siempre temblando y siempre asustado las
monjitas me siento quítate tú te vas a
ir atrás y lo único que vas a hacer te
vamos a cortar el pelo pelón cuando
termine la charla nosotros los
restaurantes vas a decir hoy la
esperanza tiene un nombre el nombre son
ustedes y yo asustado las que los
señores lloraban yo no entendía por qué
pero siempre daban dinero
las monjitas me decían que yo no sabía
hablar un día mi socio me dijo yo un día
voy a dar un te dije eso es mucho soñar
pero me gusta yo quisiera dar un tête
entonces me aferré a las repeticiones
a certificaciones a oratoria y
declamación hoy sigo nervioso pero
entiendo que las repeticiones me
cumplieron este sueño yo estoy aquí
porque me enfoqué en tu repetición es tu
reputación
mucha gente allá afuera les va a decir
que no pueden que no tienen talento como
yo quédense con esta frase lo que no
tienen de talento lo compensan con
esfuerzo lo compensan con repetición es
muy importante que esto no se les olvide
ahora cómo puedo lograr la repetición
suena muy fácil sencillo son tres cosas
todos los días te vas a levantar con la
mejor actitud posible levántate y di me
veo mejor de lo que me siento estoy
cansado ojeroso con sueño sin ilusiones
la vida me ha tratado mal
me levanto con la mejor actitud posible
2 hoy lo voy a hacer mejor que ayer ayer
y serias lagartijas hoy hago diez y
media ayer leí una página y leo una
página una palabra ayer corrí un
kilómetro y corro un kilómetro un metro
hoy lo voy a hacer mejor
que la otra vez yo sé que este es mi
primer test mi repetición me va a hacer
que cuando del quinto lo voy a hacer
mejor porque me apego a la repetición y
tercero
un día a la vez lo que realmente vale la
pena se construye en el mediano y en el
largo plazo
tercer gran acelerador vivir en modos
energético la esencia del movimiento mi
más grande sueño la unión y la
integración son fuerza la sinergia es
poder
nada representa tanto a la sinergia como
esto uno más uno es igual a tres pero la
sinergia no es de cosas no es de
máquinas es de personas para adoptar la
sinergia primero hay que ser sinergética
y un sinergética tiene tres
características
sencillas la primera es viver le gusta
dar le gusta aportar llega y pone sin
esperar nada a cambio
adam drum hace una categorización de los
tres tipos de personas que hay en el
mundo
rivers
takers y transaccionales transaccionales
yo te doy pero espero algo a cambio
el taker mi negocio mi idea mi
emprendimiento mi carro mis cosas yo
vanidad ego sólo piensa en el el cyber
es el que llega pone y dice no espero
nada a cambio de ayuda ayúdale a alguien
más esa es la primera característica
segunda característica
als energético le gustan los negocios le
gusta el crecimiento pero la fórmula de
lograrlo es una uno más uno es igual a
tres se olvida de frases como hay que
chingar al de enfrente que el de atrás
chingando viene primero mis dientes que
mis parientes de que lloren en mi casa
que yo le en la ajena que yo no en la
cena no no soy yo somos nosotros somos
equipo el crecimiento está en la
sinergia y tercera característica
entiende
y lo valioso antes que lo útil un
celular es útil
amar a una persona es valioso el dinero
que es muy útil
ver a tus hijos crecer es valioso un
carro es útil ver un amanecer es valioso
fondo antes que forman tesoro antes que
botín el sinergética entiende esto
porque para poder ayudar a alguien más
primero te tienes que ayudar a ti mismo
hoy he compartido tres grandes
aceleradores
mentalidad protagónica tus repeticiones
tu reputación y vivir en modos
energéticos erse energético de nada te
sirve tener una mentalidad correcta si
no haces el trabajo pero aún y con
mentalidad y con trabajo hay gente que
no la arma que no logra sus sueños
porque las tres palabras más difíciles
de decir son
perdóname
lo siento y ayúdame en la sinergia
necesitamos pedir ayuda y tenemos que
dar ayuda
yo quisiera terminar diciéndoles que yo
sigo soñando he logrado algunas cosas
pero dentro de mis mayores grandes
sueños
es que la gente ya no quiere ser
emprendedor que la gente quiere hacer
sinergética
que entienda el que el color rojo no es
un color si no es un recordatorio de que
no te vayas a dormir sin hacer sinergia
todo el mundo conoce la fábula y la
historia de los cangrejos los gringos
los japoneses y los mexicanos cangrejos
gringos les ponen una tapa porque son
muy fuertes y ellos salen los cangrejos
japoneses les ponen una tapa y dos
bloques por qué porque son tan unidos
que se ayudan y tumban los bloques y la
tapa cangrejos mexicanos deja los
destapados porque si quieren salir nadie
va a hacer nada se van a jalar yo sueño
con que esa historia se le cuente
diferente a nuestros hijos hay que
ponerle una tapa y 10 bloques porque
cuando lo determinen se van a salir yo
sueño con que entendamos que uno más uno
es igual a tres
la fórmula del crecimiento de todos los
que estamos aquí
entendamos que no está
en nosotros
el bien individual
está en el bien común 1 1 son 3 gracias
[Aplausos]